Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, Walking Dead
is coming back in 4 weeks and just to get
us all pumped up and ready I’m doing a weekly
countdown series of bonus videos for the characters
and some of my own personal favorites from
the last couple of seasons.
This one will be all about Rick.
Hello any new people, if you’re just finding
me I’m going to be doing weekly walking
dead videos and a weekly giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment.
I’ll be doing a Q&A tomorrow where I’ll
announce this week’s winner.
More details about all that at the end of
this.
I know farmer Rick got a lot of hate for what
went down at the prison in season 4 and all
the chaos in the aftermath but that Rick is
dead.
Long Live Farmer Rick.
Just to get things started, here’s my top
5 Rick Moments from the show so far.
Careful for spoilers from everything on the
show through Season 4.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go
Number 5 - Rick Kills Shane
Bonus points for Carl killing Walker Shane,
so Shane was killed twice in rapid succession.
I love that they give the bigger characters
epic deaths.
And they made it a family affair.
Both times Shane was put down were self defense,
Rick with the Knife and Carl with the gun.
This is one of the better examples of Rick
finding it in himself to kill one of his former
best friends.
Let that be a reminder to Professor Mullett,
Eugene or even Bob if he thinks about hitting
the bottle while they’re still trying to
escape Terminus.
I feel like Rick’s final battle with the
Governor during season 4 was just as personal,
but he and Shane shared so much between the
two of them.
They were essentially this warped messed up
family unit with Two dads and one mom.
Shane had been headed down hill all season,
so by the time Rick took him out I felt almost
no sympathy for him.
Although, do you remember back in the second
half of season 4 when Rick and Carl break
into that house.
Carl breaks down and throws Shane in Rick’s
face.
They said, behind the scenes, the actors were
thinking of the most messed up terrible thing
Carl could say to Rick, just to get him to
react.
And they came up with Shane.
Number 4 - Rick Kills Dave’s Gang in Season
It was episode 9, the mid season premiere.
This is a classic example of quick tempered
Rick shooting first and asking questions later.
He and Herschel were at Hatlin’s bar talking
about Herschel’s dead wife and being guilty
about how he’d led Maggie and Beth on about
her condition.
Cut to random appearance by Michael Raymond
James from Terriers and Tony who were part
of a large group of nomads.
They press Rick and Herschel about the location
of the farm so they can bring the group but
push comes to shove and Rick just ain’t
havin’ it.
He finishes Dave off with a headshot, but
Tony who’s huge takes three bullets before
he goes down.
I feel like everytime the show does a bar
scene, something terrible happens.
So anytime a new one shows up I’ve always
thought it’s the director reminding us visually
that this is like the opposite of cheers.
You will never be glad you came.
Number 3 - Rick Hacks of Herschel’s Leg
This was from the season 3 premiere and that
leg did not go quickly.
It was really messy and really awesome at
the same time.
Herschel makes the mistake of assuming a body
lying on the floor is completely dead but
it reanimates, bites him and Rick performs
surgery right there on the spot.
The hack job was something right out of a
b-horror movie, which was probably just as
much fun for the props team to set up as it
was for us to watch it unfold on tv.
But after it’s all done, everyone looks
up from the mess and sees all a new group
of survivors walk up with WTF faces like what
just happened here.
I think a lot of the season 4 complaints people
had during the time at the prison were mostly
that it felt like a long slow rot compared
to the crazy intensity of moments like this.
It’s always interesting to hear Scott Gimple
and the other cast members talk about changes
to the tone of the show from half season to
half season.
Thematically every 8 episodes, they completely
change what the show is.
Number 2 - Rick Clears The Prison Like a Video
Game
This was also from that same first episode
in season 3.
The survivors had the task of clearing the
prison for habitation.
And it just turns into this video game killing
spree.
Like Rick is just chopping meat in a barrel.
This is what I’m hoping to see again in
Season 5.
maybe even the first episode.
It would be a nice callback to them clearing
the prison.
Only instead of clearing Terminus so they
can live there, they clear it so they can
escape.
Some of the cooler takedowns are when they
start finding the armored guard walkers.
Armor that Glenn then later used to escape
in season 4.
Number 1 - Rick Bites out Joe’s Neck
This is the best example of crazy Rick.
The I don’t give a crap about anything but
making this threat in front of me go away.
It was one of the crazier scenes from the
comic book, usually the show is totally different,
but it does do some of the bigger stuff from
the comic.
It was like Rick shook off whatever funk had
been on him the whole season and roared back
to life all over Joe’s neck.
They said that when they filmed the scene,
Greg Nicotero came up to Andrew Lincoln and
said Chicken or Fish.
And Andrew Lincoln took a sec till it was
explained the chunk of neck he’d be biting
out would be uncooked meat.
He chose the chicken.
And he said the actor playing Joe just told
him to really lay into it.
Like go crazy.
The whole thing was surreal.
And that next morning when he and Daryl are
sitting there in the mess of the dead claimers.
Rick seems totally over it.
Like he’s already moved on.
I’ve been calling him Machine Gun Rick when
I refer to season 5 stuff, but really we should
just call him Crazy Rick.
Like stab you in a dirty alleyway Rick.
If any of you really didn’t like season
4 in general, I think a lot of your prayers
for more action have been answered with this
first half of season 5.
I’ve been following the production as they
shoot the second half of season 5, so just
turn the volume down till this tag goes away
if you don’t want to know what’s going
on...okay.
So it seems like the second half of season
5 is going to be spent on the run.
The survivors that is.
I still haven’t seen beth and it seems like
they continued to shoot at that creepy hospital
we saw her at in the trailer.
okay spoilers over.
I don’t want to use the term Hunters, just
because that’s a whole group in the comics,
but Rick is much more of a predator running
point for the survivors.
I can’t show it here in this video but during
comic con they aired a gag reel of Andrew
Lincoln warming up for scenes by screaming
obscenities running around punching stuff
like he was warming up for a boxing match.
That’s the kind of Rick I’m really excited
to see this year.
Once the episodes start we can talk more about
character arcs, but for the first couple of
episodes it’s going to be all claws and
teeth.
Here’s a big question for you guys.
What’s you favorite badass Rick Grimes moment
from the show.
If you’ve read the comics it’s okay to
comment on something from that but please
use spoiler tags.
Here’s the details on the giveaway, the
bonus videos and what’s going to happen
when episodes start.
The premiere is Sunday October 12th.
For the next 3 weeks I’ll be doing bonus
countdown videos just to help get everyone
ready.
Then when we to the actual weekend of the
premiere I might do a little bit extra.
The weekly giveaway is just like my season
4 giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment.
I’ll keep reminding people every time I
post a bonus video.
So no worries.
I’ll probably do a double giveaway for the
first episode.
My videos for the episodes will be just like
last year.
It’s the same thing I’m doing for Doctor
Who right now.
Bonus video, Episode Review and then next
day Q&A.
Feel free to make requests for those bonus
videos.
I will be doing a Q&A video for this tomorrow
morning.
There’s a bunch of other stuff starting
next week too.
So I encourage you to check it all out as
I post stuff.
It’s going to be a lot of fun!
Right now click here for my breakdown of the
season 5 trailer and click here to learn what’s
happening with the walking dead spinoff show.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!